I'm Sigourney Weaver, and I just want to say, hey, buckle up. Here comes a new smartlist. This is, listen, we're panning Sean's billiard room at his house that's now become your office. Wait a second. Pan that again. He has such a beautiful office. I put a pool table in this room because like an old pool table that was cheap, because Don't, don't, don't try.
我是西格妮·韦弗，我只想说，系好安全带。一个新的智能列表来了。这是，听着，我们正在把肖恩家里的台球室移入镜头，那里现在成了你的办公室。等一下。再把镜头移过去。他有一间多么漂亮的办公室啊。我在这个房间里放了一张台球桌，就像一张便宜的老台球桌，因为别，别，别试了。
So it's true. Yeah. It was cheap. I got the cheapest yacht I could find. It floats. It's got a beautiful sail. No, no. And so I was like, because, because it was like this little room that was an office and
所以这是真的。是的。它很便宜。我买了我能找到的最便宜的游艇。它能浮起来。它有一张漂亮的帆。不，不。所以我想，因为，因为这就像是一个作为办公室的小房间，然后
I was like, I don't need an office. I just need, where's he? Is he in Toronto? Yeah. He's at his parents place. Oh, there he is. Listener, Arnett is late, but he's clearly on Toronto time. So that's okay.
我觉得我不需要办公室。我只需要，他在哪儿？他在多伦多吗？是的。他在他父母家。哦，他在这儿。听众朋友们，阿奈特迟到了，但他显然是按多伦多时间来的。所以没关系。
Are you and, you're in mom's, we were just talking about Sean's billiard room and now you're in your parents' study or library, is it? Yeah. I'm in my, I'm in my, sorry. I'm in my dad's study. Sorry. Really? Okay.
你和，你在妈妈的，我们刚才还在聊肖恩的台球室，现在你在你父母的书房还是图书馆里？是的。我在我的，我在我的，对不起。我在我爸爸的书房里。对不起。真的吗？好吧。
So you all have, you know, I'm just in the room above the garage. Yeah, right. I'm just keeping things real. Oh yeah. You keep it really real. Yeah. Really real. What else is, what's near that room?
所以你们都有，你知道的，我只是在车库上面的房间里。是的，没错。我只是在保持真实。哦，是的。你保持得非常真实。是的。非常真实。还有什么，那个房间附近有什么？
Is your workout room and your sauna near that room? Well, I have a bunch of things in this one small little space. Yeah. I mean, I got to move the microphone out of the way. If I want to, you know, work out in this room and then if I want to get dressed or shower, I've got to, you know, move the workout stuff out of the way. Hey, you know, you know, my dad's name is Jim, right? Jim Arnett.
你的健身房和桑拿房在那个房间附近吗v？嗯，我在这个小小的空间里放了很多东西。是的。我的意思是，我得把麦克风移开。如果我想，你知道的，在这个房间里健身，然后如果我想穿衣服或洗澡，我得，你知道的，把健身器材移开。嘿，你知道，你知道，我爸爸叫吉姆，对吧？吉姆·阿奈特。
Congratulations. And did you guys know that he likes to drink highlighters? It's a mug of highlighters. It's a mug of highlighters. It's holding up a mug that says Jim on it. A mug that says Jim and then. What are you doing in Toronto, Will? Just robbing your folks place.
恭喜。你们知道他喜欢喝荧光笔吗？这是一个装满荧光笔的杯子。这是一个装满荧光笔的杯子。他正举着一个写着“吉姆”字样的杯子。一个写着“吉姆”的杯子，然后。你在多伦多做什么，威尔？只是去你父母家打劫。
I'm just doing, I'm doing a little thing here for my, my friends over at Freedom Mobile, which is a great place. If you're looking, you know, to get a great deal on one of their big gig unlimited plans is on our freedom mobile.ca. Is that what you're doing there? You're working? Yeah. Yeah.
我只是在做，我为我在自由移动的朋友们做点小事，这是一个好地方。如果你在寻找，你知道的，想在他们的那些超大流量无限套餐里找个大优惠，就在我们的 freedom mobile.ca。这就是你在那里做的事？你在工作？是的。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Sometimes I make myself laugh. Do you? Yeah. Just need me. That's it. Well, you get all driving around all day.
是的。是的。有时候我自己都能把自己逗笑。是吗？是的。只需要我。就是这样。好吧，你整天开车到处跑。
You get a lot of you, you get a lot of you. You guys, I went on a haunted hayride the other day. Sounded out. Yep. Haunted hayride. Yeah. Have you guys ever been to that one in Los Angeles? The hayride?
你有很多你，你有很多你。你们，我前几天去坐了鬼屋干草车。听起来很土。是的。鬼屋干草车。是的。你们去过洛杉矶的那一个吗？那个干草车？
Well, I think when I was six or seven. Oh, come on. It's fun. Yep. No. Abel did it a couple of weeks ago. It's fun, right? So somebody not yet a teenager.
嗯，我想我六、七岁的时候去过。哦，拜托。挺好玩的。是的。没有。阿贝尔几周前才去过。挺好玩的，对吧？所以一个还不是十几岁的人。
We're 12. We're 12. And so how was it, Sean? It's fun. It's like, you guys, I think you would like it. It's like, you know, you're getting a wagon with a bunch of people and, you know, you go through Griffith Park and they scare the crap out of you. It's kind of fun.
我们12岁。我们12岁。那么，感觉怎么样，肖恩？挺好玩的。就像是，你们，我想你们会喜欢的。就像是，你知道的，你和一堆人坐上一辆马车，然后，你知道的，你们穿过格里菲斯公园，他们把你吓个半死。挺好玩的。
Really? It's like a haunted hayride. Like they, the people run out of the bushes and stuff. Yeah. Yeah. You know, speaking of bushes in Griffith Park, this is your story. I used to run outside. Now I, now I run here in the, my small little closet of a room here with a treadmill.
真的吗？就像鬼屋干草车一样。就像他们，人们从灌木丛里冲出来什么的。是的。是的。你知道的，说到格里菲斯公园的灌木丛，这就是你的故事了。我以前在外面跑步。现在我，现在我在这跑步，在这个我那配有跑步机的狭小如壁橱的房间里。
But I used to run through Griffith Park and, and I'd tell, I tell my friends, boy, you know, I did the friendliest people in Griffith Park, you know, I kept running by these guys. They just kept waving at me and they said, you know, what, what time of day do you run it? I said, boy, I don't know. Like right around, you know, late morning or early, like around lunchtime. Yep, at lunchtime at Griffith Park, famously supposedly you can just take a walk or a jog and find any dude you want by a bush and he'll, he'll give you an HJ, a BJ, whatever, it depends
但我以前经常穿过格里菲斯公园，而且，我告诉我的朋友们，天哪，你知道吗，格里菲斯公园里的人最友好了，你知道的，我一直从这些家伙身边跑过。他们只是不停地向我挥手，他们说，你知道，你通常几点跑步？我说，天哪，我不知道。大概就在，你知道的，上午晚些时候或者早一点，比如午饭时间左右。是的，在格里菲斯公园的午饭时间，据说你可以随便散步或慢跑，在任何灌木丛旁找到你想要的任何帅哥，他会，他会给你来个手淫、口交，随便什么，这取决于
on how much money you're holding. But there's a section there in Griffith Park where it's just hooked up central. That's why when I asked Sean for a good place to jog, he said Griffith Park and I said, he said, cause it's very handy and you thought it was just centrally located. Yeah. I have never heard of that story. Yeah. All right.
你手里拿着多少钱。但在格里菲斯公园里有这么一个地方，简直就是各种勾搭的中心。这就是为什么当我向肖恩打听慢跑的好去处时，他说格里菲斯公园，然后我说，他说，因为那里非常方便，而你以为它只是地理位置居中。是的。我从来没听过这个故事。是的。好吧。
So let's get to our guests, which I'm so excited, but it's a wonderful segue. Great. All right. So I, I know I'm always excited for my guests, but this one is a kind of like a mic drop. Okay. Your eighties childhood dreams are going to come true. Your nineties childhood dreams, your 2000 childhood dreams. And your current dreams.
那么让我们来介绍我们的嘉宾，我太兴奋了，这是一个美妙的过渡。太棒了。好吧。所以，我知道我总是为我的嘉宾感到兴奋，但这次有点像扔下一枚重磅炸弹。好的。你八十年代的童年梦想将会成真。你九十年代的童年梦想，你两千年代的童年梦想。以及你当前的梦想。
This woman is at the center of all your favorite iconic franchises that we'll talk about there. Born and raised in Manhattan. She went to the same two schools I did, Stanford and Yale. So of course she speaks three languages. Sure. I don't know what they are, but she loves gardening and is afraid of elevators. As far as her work goes, as far as her work goes, if you don't blink, she was in Annie Hall for like six seconds.
这个女人是你所有最喜欢的标志性特许经营权的核心，我们稍后会谈到。在曼哈顿出生长大。她上了我和她一样的两所学校，斯坦福和耶鲁。所以她当然会说三种语言。当然。我不知道是哪三种，但她喜欢园艺，而且恐高——不，害怕电梯。至于她的工作，至于她的工作，如果你不眨眼的话，她在《安妮·霍尔》里演了大约六秒钟。
The respect and love and admiration she gets in this business of ours is as tall as she is. Guys, it's one of my favorite actresses of all time. Sigourney Weaver. Whoa. Sigourney Weaver. Sigourney Weaver. It is Sigourney Weaver.
她在我们这行里得到的尊重、爱和钦佩和她的人一样高。伙计们，这是我最喜欢的所有时代的女演员之一。西格妮·韦弗。哇。西格妮·韦弗。西格妮·韦弗。真的是西格妮·韦弗。
There she is. It's so glamorous. Hi, you guys. I'm so excited to be here. Oh, how cool. By the way, you, you look beautiful and, and you know, you didn't have to like shush up for us because nobody's going to see that. Oh, I didn't.
她在那儿。太迷人了。嗨，你们好。我很高兴能来到这里。哦，太酷了。顺便说一句，你，你看上去真漂亮，而且，你知道的，你其实不用特意为了我们嘘声安静下来，因为没有人会看到那个。哦，我没吗？
Yeah. No, she's doing something important after this. You watch. This is the way I look. You know, when I'm vacuuming the house and doing the dishes. Unbelievable. Oh, I did it. It's my favorite response to that.
是的。不，她在这之后还要做一些重要的事情。你瞧着吧。这就是我的样子。你知道的，当我正在用吸尘器打扫房子和洗碗的时候。难以置信。哦，我做到了。这是我对此最喜欢的回答。
Sigourney, have you ever been to Griffith Park? I have, but I think I was on a horse, so I missed all the fun. So was I. Don't take a sip after that. Yeah, you're not allowed to take a little comedy sip. Sigourney Weaver, welcome to the show. My God, this is such an honor to have you. It really is.
西格妮，你以前去过格里菲斯公园吗？我去过，但我想我当时是骑着马的，所以我错过了所有的乐趣。我也是。在那之后可别喝水。是的，你不准喝一小口喜剧之水。西格妮·韦弗，欢迎来到节目。天哪，有你做客真是太荣幸了。真的。
Oh, well, that's very sweet of you. But by the time our segment is over, I don't know that you'll feel like that, but it's very kind of you to say. No, I, I've been a big fan of this show and of each of you, and I'm delighted to be here. Well, it's impossible in place wise. I didn't know, you're probably so sick of talking about this. I didn't know your real name was Susan Sue. Wait, what?
哦，好吧，你太甜了。但等我们的环节结束时，我不知道你是否还会这么觉得，不过你这么说真是太好了。不，我，我一直是这个节目和你们每个人的超级粉丝，我很高兴能来到这里。好吧，从地点上来说这不可能。我不知道，你可能已经厌烦了谈论这个。我不知道你的真名叫苏珊、苏。等等，什么？
Yeah. Yeah. Sue and Susie. And does anybody call you Sue or Susie? Well, they, you know, you can't change your destiny. I did change my name to Sigourney when I was about 13, but now everyone calls me Siggy. So, you know, I was trying to get a longer name because by that time I was almost six feet tall when I was 11.
对。对。苏和苏茜。有人叫你苏或苏茜吗？嗯，他们，你知道的，你无法改变你的命运。我大约13岁时把名字改成了西格妮，但现在大家都叫我西吉。所以，你知道的，我当时想弄个更长的名字，因为那时候我11岁时就快六英尺高了。
So I thought Susie is too diminutive. And Susie Snowflake. There's Susie Snowflake. Yeah. Yeah. Or wake up little Susie or all those. You know. Or Susie cream cheese.
所以我认为苏茜太小家子气了。还有苏茜雪花。有苏茜雪花。是的。是的。或者醒醒吧小苏茜或诸如此类的。你知道的。或者苏茜奶油奶酪。
Yes. Yeah. And from the great Gatsby, right? Is that what you thought of me? That's right. I saw it. It's mentioned once. What is Sigourney?
是的。是的。还有来自《了不起的盖茨比》，对吧？这就是你想到我的原因？没错。我看到了。里面提到过一次。什么是西格妮？
I think it's Jordan Baker's aunt is mentioned and it's like Mrs. Sigourney Fay or something like that. And I just looked, it was an S case. I liked the initial and it just went on for a long time. And then why, which I think is very up to. And your parents? Yeah. What did your parents say?
我想里面提到了乔丹·贝克的姑妈，大概叫西格妮·费夫人或者类似的名字。我只是看了一下，那是一个S开头的名字。我喜欢这个首字母，而且这个词很长。然后为什么，我认为这非常符合。还有你的父母？是的。你父母怎么说？
They were like, Hey, we give you a nice name and now you've decided. What kind of thanks is this? Yeah. Yeah. They did call me S for a long time in case I changed it again. But ironically, my mother was named Desiree because they'd had like eight boys and finally they had a girl. But everyone called her Liz and my father was named Sylvester.
他们就像是，嘿，我们给你起了个好名字，现在你决定改了。这是什么谢意？是的。他们确实叫了我好一阵子的“S”，以防我再次改名。但讽刺的是，我母亲名叫德西雷，因为他们已经生了大约八个男孩，终于生了个女孩。但大家都叫她莉兹，我父亲名叫西尔维斯特。
But because he was a little redheaded kid, he and his brother, they were called Pat and Mike. So he was Pat. So they couldn't say anything to me. You come from a long line of people who are not happy with the names they were given. Exactly. What about your middle name? It begins with a name.
但因为他是个红头发的小男孩，他和他的兄弟被称为帕特和迈克。所以他是帕特。所以他们什么也不能对我说。你出身于一个对被赋予的名字不满的家族。完全正确。你的中间名呢？是以什么名字开头的。
Alexandra. Alexandra. Oh, that's a beautiful name. It's my mother's name. It's a bit long. Yeah. But Alex is a great short for a woman. But I knew a really obnoxious girl named Alex at camp.
亚历山德拉。亚历山德拉。哦，那是个好名字。这是我母亲的名字。有点长。是的。但亚历克斯对女性来说是个很棒的简称。但我在夏令营里认识一个极其讨厌的女孩叫亚历克斯。
So I couldn't do that. What about brothers and sisters? Were they equally unhappy with their names? Well, no. My father was a rumored history nut. So he named my brother Trajan after a really wonderful emperor. And he wanted to name me Flavia, which my mother said. Now that I would have changed.
所以我不能用那个。兄弟姐妹呢？他们对自己的名字也同样不满意吗？嗯，不。我父亲是个出了名的历史迷。所以他用一个非常优秀的皇帝图拉真给我的兄弟取名为图拉真。他想给我起名叫弗拉维娅，我母亲说。现在这个我肯定会改的。
Flavia. Yeah. Oh my God. That sounds so close to something else. I know. I know. This is a very rich history. This is an incredible, it was happening at your house.
弗拉维娅。是的。天哪。这听起来跟别的什么太像了。我知道。我知道。这是一段非常丰富的历史。这是一个不可思议的，在你们家发生的事。
These are interesting people. I know. I'm dead serious. I like it. I'm sorry. First of all, my mother's name is Alexandra. My partner's name is Alessandra. And my son's first name is, his real first name is Alexander.
这些人很有趣。我知道。我是认真的。我喜欢。对不起。首先，我母亲的名字叫亚历山德拉。我伴侣的名字叫亚历山德拉。我儿子的名字，他真正的名是亚历山大。
Well, Alexander the Great. So Alexander the Great. And do you know that a woman traditionally spelled Alex when they shorted with an I? That's how you differentiate between- Oh, Alex. Yes. I understand that. I see that.
嗯，亚历山大大帝。所以亚历山大大帝。你知道女人通常把亚历克斯拼写为用一个I结尾的吗？这就是你如何区分——哦，亚历克斯。是的。我明白。我明白了。
What, A-L-I-Ax? Yeah. My mom spells that A-L-I-Ax. Does she really? Mm-hmm. Wait, Sigourney, how many brothers and sisters did you have? I have one brother. One brother.
什么，A-L-I-Ax？是的。我妈妈把它拼成 A-L-I-Ax。她真的这样拼吗？嗯——哼。等等，西格妮，你有多少兄弟姐妹？我有一个兄弟。一个兄弟。
And then growing up. So what was growing up like? That you could just be like, I want to change my name and they're like, great. Was it like, crunchy in 60s and love and whatever? Well, my father was working, he was head of NBC in the 50s. Oh, wow. So he produced show of shows and created the Today Show and the Tonight Show. Come on.
然后在成长过程中。所以成长过程是怎样的？以至于你可以直接说：我想改名，然后他们说：太棒了？是不是那种60年代嬉皮士、充满爱与自由的风格？嗯，我父亲当时在工作，他在50年代是NBC的负责人。哦，哇。所以他制作了《秀中秀》，并创建了《今日秀》和《今夜秀》。拜托。
He did? All of that. Hang on. Wait a minute. This is your guest. This has got to be covered on the Work of TV page. I didn't know this. I didn't know this.
他做到了？所有这些。等一下。等一下。这是你的嘉宾。这必须登上电视工作页面。我不知道这个。我不知道这个。
Yeah. Higher will. What's his name? Sylvester. Sylvester Pat Weaver. Sylvester. Sylvester. And she just said it.
是的。厉害了威尔。他叫什么名字？西尔维斯特。西尔维斯特·帕特·韦弗。西尔维斯特。西尔维斯特。她刚说过了。
I didn't know that. And Jimmy Fallon just said nice things about him the other night when, you know, they think of him as their, the father of the Tonight Show. Sylvester Weaver. Yeah. Yeah. Sylvester Pat. Okay.
我不知道。吉米·法伦前几天还说了一些关于他的好话，当时，你知道的，他们把他视为《今夜秀》之父。西尔维斯特·韦弗。是的。西尔维斯特·帕特。好吧。
Pat Weaver is really what he's called. So what's so crazy is I met you once for two seconds backstage at The Tonight Show. When I was like 27 years old. And just three years ago. Really made a real imprint on her. Yeah. So we passed each other in the hall in the back. I just think that's wild.
帕特·韦弗确实就是人们对他的称呼。所以最疯狂的是我曾在《今夜秀》后台见过你两秒钟。当我大约27岁的时候。就在三年前。真的给她留下了深刻的印象。我们在后台走廊擦肩而过。我只是觉得这太疯狂了。
I was like, oh my God. Hi. Nice to meet you. And you were like, hi. Nice to meet you. So then does that mean your childhood was around show business? And is that where you got your taste for it or was that later? I was very shy.
我当时想，噢，天哪。嗨。很高兴认识你。而你却说，嗨。很高兴认识你。那这是否意味着你的童年是在演艺圈度过的？这就是你对它产生兴趣的地方，还是那是后来的事？我很害羞。
So I don't think I imagined even developing a taste for it. But what I must say is my father would come home after the day, I guess before he went back for the night shows. And he always seemed in a good mood. He was always laughing. And I thought, and we had lots of, you know, we had, we had those people come in and out like Red Skelton and Jackie Gleason did their, you know, this is your life. So he was working with people who sounded absolutely wonderful to me.
所以我想我甚至没想过要对它产生兴趣。但我必须说的是，我父亲一天工作结束后回家，我想是在他返回夜间节目之前。他总是显得心情很好。他总是笑个不停。而且我想，我们有很多，你知道的，我们有，我们有那些人来来往往，比如雷·斯凯尔顿和杰基·格里森做了他们的，你知道的，这是你的人生。所以他合作的人在我听来简直棒极了。
So it took me many, many years to say I want to be an actor for various different reasons. But I guess I was always maybe trying to head toward a little area of that world because I knew it was hard work and unpredictable and often unfair, which I think is a great advantage to know that going in. But I also knew my father laughed a lot during the day. But wait a second. What an interesting thing though, so he creates the today show and the tonight show. And he's doing them simultaneously, working on them.
所以我花了许多许多年才说出我想成为一名演员，原因有很多不同。但我想我可能一直在努力朝着那个世界的一小块区域前进，因为我知道这很辛苦、不可预测而且常常不公平，我认为带着这种认知入行是一个巨大的优势。但我也知道我父亲在白天笑了很多次。但等一下。不过这是一件多么有趣的事啊，他创建了《今日秀》和《今夜秀》。而且他同时在做这两档节目，为之工作。
Well, first he was running the network. And so he had the regular shows, like show of shows, but then the network, the world could not imagine having any kind of TV on in the early morning. And they couldn't imagine TV on at night. So it sort of went from, I don't know, five to eight. It was very limited in those days in the early 50s. So when he pitched to the general Sarnoff who owned RCA and NBC that he wanted to do this morning show, people should wake up in the morning, be able to turn on TV, find out
嗯，他最初是负责整个电视网的。所以他有常规节目，比如《秀中秀》，但当时电视网，全世界都无法想象在清晨有什么电视节目。他们也无法想象晚上有电视节目。所以它大概从，我不知道，五点到八点。在5年代初的那些日子里，这是非常有限的。所以当他向拥有RCA和NBC的萨诺夫将军提出他想做这个早间节目时，人们应该在早上醒来，能够打开电视，了解
what happened overnight, get a few laughs from Dave Garroway and all that stuff. The general was horrified and my father pushed it through anyway and it's still running. And maybe you can answer that because I remember hearing once years ago that the idea of the late night program, i.e. the tonight show was part, that it was empty airways, but also so that the last thing people did was leave their TV on that channel so that the next day when you turned your TV on, it was they had, they already had your attention. That's right. Did you ever hear that from your dad?
昨晚发生了什么，从戴夫·加罗韦那里得到一些欢笑等等。将军吓坏了，但我父亲还是硬着头皮把它推行下去了，而且现在还在热播。也许你可以回答这个问题，因为我记得多年前听过一次，深夜节目的概念，也就是《今夜秀》，有一部分原因是当时空气中空空如也，但也是为了让人们做的最后一件事是将电视停留在那个频道，这样第二天当你打开电视时，他们已经吸引了你的注意力。没错。你从你爸爸那里听过这个吗？
I did. Yeah. I'm not talking to you. He wasn't telling me the secrets of NBC, but it's a good idea. I'm Sigourney, sidebar. I'm doing a play on Broadway next year. What's it called? I'm playing Oskar Levant and the play takes place backstage at the tonight show.
我听过。是的。我才没跟你说话呢。他没有把NBC的秘密告诉我，但这是个好主意。西格妮，顺便说一下。我明年要在百老汇出演一出戏。叫什么名字？我将扮演奥斯卡·黎凡特，这出戏的背景发生在《今夜秀》的后台。
Wow. Yeah. Can I do a walkthrough? Yes, please. Like a ghost. Now wait, I didn't know that, so when I was in college, we were obsessed with Christopher Durang. Yes.
哇。是的。我可以去跑龙套吗？好的，请吧。像个幽灵一样。现在等等，我不知道这个，所以在上大学时，我们对克里斯托弗·杜兰格着迷得不行。是的。
I was like, oh my God, let's do a Christopher Durang play because it was the, he was kind of like the Neil Simon of our generation, right? And I would look at the opening of all his plays, I was like, it would be like starring Sigourney Weaver. And I was like, wait, the movie star was on in play. Like as a first time at such a young age, I realized, oh, as an actor, you just weren't, you couldn't just be one thing. You could do all the things.
我当时想，噢，天哪，让我们演一出克里斯托弗·杜兰格的戏吧，因为他就像是我们那一代人的尼尔·西蒙，对吧？我看着他所有戏剧的开场，我会想，主演会是西格妮·韦弗。我当时想，等等，这个电影明星在演话剧？作为人生第一次，在如此年轻的时候，我意识到，哦，作为一名演员，你不能仅仅局限于一种角色。你可以尝试所有的角色。
But I was blown away to see your name as the original cast in so many Broadway plays. Yeah. I think you said starring. I think we just had our names. Oh, well, yeah. The characters. Right. That's what I mean.
但我看到你的名字作为原卡出演了那么多百老汇戏剧，我简直惊呆了。是的。我想你说的是主演。我想我们当时只是把名字放上去了。哦，好吧。角色。没错，我是这个意思。
Yeah. No, but that's how I, you know, that saved me because I was quite discouraged at drama school. And luckily, when I came to New York, even though I was looking for a job in a florist store or anywhere, you know, a cake store, anywhere but a show business because I'd been so discouraged, you know, I kept working with Chris and all our friends and all of Broadway. And I'm so grateful that that is how I started with about five years of drama. And all those comedies.
是的。不，但这就是我，你知道的，那拯救了我，因为我在戏剧学校时相当沮丧。幸运的是，当我来到纽约时，尽管我在花店或任何地方找工作，你知道的，糕点店，任何与演艺圈无关的地方，因为我太沮丧了，你知道的，我一直和克里斯以及我们的所有朋友还有整个百老汇合作。我非常感激我是以大约五年的戏剧经验开始的。还有所有那些喜剧。
Yeah. They were all comedies. And Albert in a rotto and all the, all the gang. Do you still do a bunch of theater? Do you have, even have time to do want to? I did. We did Vanya, Sonya, Masha and Spike on Broadway for a year, just about in 2013. And then since then, I've been doing avatar avatar and some other stuff.
是的。它们全都是喜剧。还有阿尔伯特以及那一帮人。你现在还经常演话剧吗？你甚至有时间去做或者想去做吗？演过。我们在2013年左右在百老汇演了一年的《万尼亚、索尼亚、玛莎和斯派克》。从那以后，我一直在拍《阿凡达》、《阿凡达》以及其他一些东西。
For them. I haven't heard of it. Wow. When does that come out? Avatar two is coming out December 16. And did you, didn't you shoot the third one at the same time? Well, there's like five. Yeah.
为了他们。我没听说过。哇。那部什么时候上映？《阿凡达2》将于12月16日上映。难道你没有，你不是同时拍摄了第三部吗？嗯，大概有五部。是的。
Two and three. There will be five. It's all part of one long story about this family. I love it. It's so great. You know, it's so funny because the, you know, the avatar came out to such fanfare and success and was, you know, really well received critically and at the box off, et cetera, to then have this follow-up, this film that's been made as you can attest to for a long time.
第二部和第三部。总共有五部。这都是关于这个家族的一个长篇故事的一部分。我喜欢。太棒了。你知道的，太有趣了，因为，你知道的，第一部《阿凡达》上映时引发了巨大的轰动和成功，并且，你知道的，在评论界和票房等方面都广受好评，然后有了这部续集，这部正如你所证明的那样制作了很长时间的电影。
And there's a lot of surrounding it to just call it avatar two seems sort of, sort of unceremonial. No, it's the way of the water. The way of water. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Well, and cause James Cameron has this like fascination with water.
而且周围有很多围绕着它的东西，仅仅把它叫做《阿凡达2》似乎有点，有点不够隆重。不，它叫《水之道》。水之道。是的。好吧。好吧，因为詹姆斯·卡梅隆对水有着这种迷恋。
We don't, I don't, I, you know, hopefully he'll come on the show one day. Yeah. But wait, but tell me about, didn't you have to like learn how to breathe? And didn't you film underwater for like a long time? She learned how to breathe underwater. Tell us about that. Yes. I'll just show you my gills.
我们不会，我不会，我，你知道的，希望他有一天能来上节目。是的。但是等等，但是告诉我，你是不是必须得学会如何呼吸？你是不是在水下拍了好长时间？她学会了在水下呼吸。给我们讲讲那个吧。是的。我直接给你看我的鳃。
No, but I, we did, we actually worked with Kirk Crack who teaches the Navy SEALs. And Jim doesn't do anything by have. So he really wanted us to be comfortable in the water and be able to do scenes underwater. So we studied for a whole year with Kirk and we all had to do breath holes, which you trained to get up to and I was able finally to do a static breath hold for six and a half minutes. Oh my God. I can't, that's unbelievable.
不，但是我们，我们实际上和教海豹突击队的柯克·克拉克合作过。吉姆做事从来不是半途而废的。所以他真的很想让我们在水里感到舒适，并能够在水下表演场景。所以我们和柯克一起学习了一整年，我们都必须练习憋气，你通过训练来达到目标，我最终能够进行长达六分半钟的静态憋气。噢，天哪。我不能，这太难以置信了。
But anyone can do it if you have Kirk Crack. My husband was with me because he trained with me. We both did it that day for six and a half minutes and neither of us can believe it. Wow. And we will be right back. This is supported by Audible, you don't ride an elevator for the music or pick an airline for the movie. So when it comes to audio entertainment, it makes sense to choose Audible.
但只要你有柯克·克拉克，任何人都能做到。我丈夫和我在一起，因为他和我们一起训练。我们俩那天都做到了六分半钟，我们俩都不敢相信。哇。我们马上回来。本节目由Audible赞助支持，你不会为了听音乐而去坐电梯，也不会为了看电影去挑航空公司。所以在选择音频娱乐时，选择Audible是顺理成章的。
It's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke or Kerry Washington, Kevin Hart. It's home to epic adventures and chilling mysteries and can't miss comedies. Audible is the home of storytelling and you know, if I'm talking about storytelling in a positive way that it must be good because for the most part I hate storytelling, especially when it comes from filmmakers, let your imagination soar with audio books, podcasts and originals. For instance, by the way, by the bee, Heat 2 just came out by Michael Mann and Meg Gardner, which is the follow up to Heat the film.
这里汇集了由伊桑·霍克、凯丽·华盛顿、凯文·哈特等超级巨星讲述的故事。这里有史诗般的冒险、令人不寒而栗的悬疑和不容错过的喜剧。Audible是讲故事的归宿，你知道的，如果我以积极的方式谈论讲故事，那它一定很棒，因为大多数情况下我讨厌讲故事，尤其是当它来自电影制作人时。让你的想象力在有声书、播客和原创作品中翱翔吧。例如，顺便说一句，迈克尔·曼和梅格·加德纳刚刚推出了《盗火线2》，这是电影《盗火线》的续集。
They wrote this book, Heat 2, narrated by voiceover legend Peter Giles, who's also happens to be one of my close mates, good guy, great guy, but he is one of the all time great narrators and this Heat 2 is unbelievable. It's riveting, it's so, it's just everything you want in that kind of thriller-y book told by a guy who really knows how to tell a story. That's just one example of what it's like. It's nonstop, unbelievable, any sort of genre, any kind of book that you want, Audible has it.
他们写了这本书《盗火线2》，由配音界传奇人物彼得·盖尔斯旁白，他恰好也是我的密友之一，好家伙，伟大的家伙，但他是有史以来最伟大的旁白者之一，这部《盗火线2》简直令人难以置信。它扣人心弦，太棒了，这完全是你在一本那种惊悚小说中所期望的一切，由一个真正懂得如何讲故事的人娓娓道来。这只是其中的一个例子。它节奏紧凑，难以置信，任何类型的流派，你想要的任何种类的书，Audible应有尽有。
It's the home of storytelling with all your audio entertainment in one app. Audible has an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries, thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, everything, just all that and more. So as an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. Members also get full access to a growing selection of included audiobooks, Audible Originals and podcasts.
它是讲故事的大本营，将你所有的音频娱乐汇集在一个应用中。Audible在各个流派中拥有令人难以置信的有声书精选，从畅销书和新书发布到名人回忆录、悬疑、惊悚、励志、健康、商业，应有尽有，不仅如此，还有更多。因此，作为Audible的会员，你每个月可以从他们的整个目录中挑选一本永久保留的图书，包括最新的畅销书和新书发布。会员还可以完全访问不断增加的精选有声书、Audible原创作品和播客。
You can download or stream our included titles all you want. Let Audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired or be entertained. New members can try for free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Every week, Storyworth will email your loved one a single life-related question that you pick from their collection, like what's the bravest thing you've ever done or what's
你可以随心所欲地下载或流式传输我们包含的书籍。让Audible帮助你发现欢笑、启发或娱乐的新方式。新会员可免费试用30天。访问 audible.com slash smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。这就是 audible.com slash smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500，免费试用 Audible 30天。每周，Storyworth都会向你爱的人发送一个与生活相关的问题，你可以从他们的收藏中挑选，比如你做过的最勇敢的事情是什么，或者
the farthest you've ever traveled. All they have to do is reply with a story. Then after a year, Storyworth compiles your loved one's stories, memories and even any photos into an exquisite hardcover book creating a valued keepsake. That is so amazing and fun and I realize I want to do that with my folks this holiday season because it would be so great to get in their own words thoughts about their own experiences from their own lives and then have that for the rest of my life and that's something that I can share with my siblings and I can share it with my kids and our whole
你去过最远的地方是哪里。他们所需要做的就是回复一个故事。然后一年后，Storyworth会把你爱的人的故事、记忆甚至任何照片汇编成一本精美的精装书，创造出一份珍贵的传家宝。这真是太棒太有趣了，我意识到我想在这个假期和我父母一起做这件事，因为能用他们自己的话听到他们对自己一生的经历的想法，然后把这作为我余生的珍藏，这该有多好，而且这是我可以与我的兄弟姐妹分享的东西，我可以与我的孩子们以及我们整个家庭分享，这是我们可以永远珍藏的东西。所以我真的很期待这样做。
family and it's something that we can hold on to. So I'm really looking forward to doing this. Millions of stories have already been told with Storyworth because they make the process so simple. So get started with your loved one for the holidays and before you know it, you'll both be cherishing those timeless stories for generations to come. Help your family share their story this holiday season with Storyworth. Go to storyworth.com slash smartless today and save $10 on your first purchase.
数百万个故事已经在Storyworth被讲述，因为他们把这个过程变得非常简单。所以在这个节日里开始和你爱的人一起创作吧，不知不觉中，你们两个就会世世代代珍视这些永恒的故事。在这个节日里帮助你的家人分享他们的故事，就用Storyworth。今天就访问 storyworth.com slash smartless，在你的首次购买中节省10美元。
That's S-T-O-R-Y-W-O-R-T-H dot com slash smartless to save $10 on your first purchase. Storyworth dot com slash smartless. Thanks Helix for their support man do we love Helix over here at smartless they've been on this ride with us since early days and we love them not just because that but also because we all sleep on Helix mattresses and we all love them. I got the Helix Midnight Lux mattress, Sean got the Helix Dusk Lux mattress and Jason also got the same thing I did the Helix Midnight Lux mattress. What's better than sleeping on a Helix mattress knowing what Helix mattress your buddy sleep
即 S-T-O-R-Y-W-O-R-T-H 点 com 斜杠 smartless，首次购买可省 10 美元。storyworth.com slash smartless。感谢Helix的支持，天哪，我们在smartless这边有多爱Helix啊，他们从早期开始就和我们一路同行，我们爱他们不仅仅因为这个，还因为我们都睡在Helix床垫上，我们都爱它们。我买的是Helix Midnight Lux床垫，肖恩买的是Helix Dusk Lux床垫，杰森买的也和我一样，是Helix Midnight Lux床垫。有什么比睡在Helix床垫上更好的呢，那就是知道你的好哥们睡的是哪个Helix床垫
on I guess. I don't know if it's better but it's good information to have anyway the point is we love them. We got Helix mattresses for the kids that are amazing these you know twin bed mattresses that the kids just they're just fantastic and Helix sleep is here's what they are they're premium mattress brand that provides tailored mattresses based on your unique sleep preferences. So the Helix lineup includes 14 unique mattresses including a collection of luxury models and a mattress for big and tall sleepers and the mattress I just mentioned that's made just
我想是的。我不知道这算不算更好，但无论如何这也是个不错的信息，重点是我们爱它们。我们给孩子们买的Helix床垫棒极了，你知道的，这些双人床垫简直太棒了。Helix Sleep是一家高端床垫品牌，根据你独特的睡眠偏好提供量身定制的床垫。所以Helix的产品线包括14款独特的床垫，包括一系列豪华型号、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，以及我刚才提到的专为儿童制造的床垫。
for kids. Is there anything worse than going to a mattress store and laying down on a mattress that that you know hundreds of other people you know have tried out before you gross wait and then you got some over eager sales associate asking probing questions order a Helix mattress online and receive an easy no contact delivery and how are you going to know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body well you're going to take the Helix sleep quiz and you're going to find your perfect mattress in under two minutes you got two minutes friend I think you do all right so you should never have to compromise on comfort Helix has mattresses
还有什么比去床垫店躺在一张你知道成百上千其他人试过的床垫上更糟糕的事吗，恶心，等等，然后你还得应付一个过于热情的销售人员问各种刺探性问题。在线订购Helix床垫，享受简单无接触的配送，你怎么知道哪款Helix床垫最适合你和你的身体呢，很简单，你要做个Helix睡眠测试，在不到两分钟的时间里找到你的完美床垫，你连两分钟都没有吗朋友，我想你是有的。好吧，所以你不必在舒适度上妥协，Helix拥有带冷却技术的床垫，无论什么季节都能帮助调节你的体温，而且这些家伙应有尽有
with cooling technology that help regulate your body temperature whatever the season and these guys they got it all Helix is offering up to $200 off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listener go to helix.com smartlist with Helix better sleep starts now back to the show now can I ask you a potentially tacky housekeeping question if if you're obligated to train for a year for a film before you start shooting are you paid for that year of training that's a very good question and we were shooting at the same time we were training so we got there in the summer of 2017 and started doing a lot of parkour yeah and I would I actually play one of the kids in avatar too so I had to do everything the
Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单最高减免200美元外加两个免费枕头的优惠，访问 helix.com slash smartless，使用Helix，优质睡眠从现在开始。言归正传，现在我可以问一个潜在的有点尴尬的后勤问题吗？如果你被要求在电影开拍前进行一年的训练，你那年的训练是有薪水的吗？这是一个非常好的问题，我们在训练的同时也在拍摄，所以我们在2017年夏天到达那里，开始做大量的跑酷
kids did and at the same time we started training she'd like shoot in the morning and then train the afternoon I'm trying to remember we had about two months of training and then when you weren't shooting they would bring you over to the little tank in Manhattan Beach and you would do more and more challenging stuff and then eventually they took us to a final sort of rehearsal off the big island and we learned how to swim with sort of underwater vehicles which would then represent other species that we might meet in the crazy she's being very careful not to reveal I should be very very careful and so Gordy Jason would love to get a hold of your day out of days maybe the one line or two yeah and if he could
是的，而且我实际上在《阿凡达2》里演一个小孩，所以我必须做孩子们做的一切，与此同时我们开始训练。她通常早上拍戏，下午训练。我努力回想了一下，我们大约有两个月的基础训练，然后当你没戏时，他们会把你带到曼哈顿海滩的小水槽里，让你做越来越多具有挑战性的事情，最后他们把我们带到大岛附近进行最终的彩排，我们学会了如何与类似水下交通工具的东西一起游泳，这些东西后来代表了我们在疯狂的拍摄中可能会遇到的其他物种。她非常小心地不愿透露——我应该非常非常小心。
get a number on the first day D just so we could work on his hardouts that would be great I need to know your turnarounds and things like that because I'm sensing there's some overtime that could be okay but wait Gordy but don't you have to do a lot of in addition to the water stuff and maybe for the other ones and I know for the first one all that motion capture green screen stuff right well may I just say yes every one of the world thinks we still do green screen I haven't done a green screen since a pickup for the first Ghostbusters that long ago so I've never done green screen that one time this is all performance capture you know like any circus yeah and it's actually kind of a wonderful
所以，戈迪，杰森很想拿到你每天的拍摄通告，也许只要一两行——是的，如果他能在第一天给你一个D（指拍摄日），好让你能处理好你的杀青时间，那就太好了。我需要知道你的转场时间之类的事情，因为我感觉到会有一些加班，那可能还可以。但是等等，戈迪，除了水下的东西之外，你是不是还必须做很多事情，也许对于其他部分，我知道对于第一部来说，所有那些动作捕捉绿幕的东西，对吧？好吧，我能说吗，是的，世界上每个人都以为我们还在用绿幕。自从很久以前为第一部《捉鬼敢死队》补拍镜头之后，我就再没用过绿幕了。所以我只用过一次绿幕。这全都是表演捕捉，
theatrical experience you don't have to worry about lights or makeup or you know it's just you and your little black suit you're a little so explain that to it to our to our Tracy's out there that no idea what that first of all green screen is something where if you stand in front of a big piece of green fabric they can later cut out all the green stuff behind you and put in a picture of mountains or whatever they want to put you in front of charging rhinoceros right now a days they have you act in front of what and and and you are wearing a suit that captures cameras tied to your head in your side right so you're in a big empty space called the volume and you may have basic sets built to run up and
你知道的，就像任何马戏团一样。这实际上是一种美妙的戏剧体验，你不必担心灯光、化妆或者别的什么，这只有你和你那身小黑衣，你那身小——所以请向我们的听众们解释一下，那些对第一部一无所知的人——首先，绿幕是指如果你站在一块巨大的绿色织物前面，他们以后可以剪掉你身后所有的绿色东西，换上一张群山的照片，或者任何他们想让你站的冲过来的犀牛前面。现在，他们让你在什么样的布景前表演，你穿着一套将摄像头系在你的头部和身侧的衣服，对吧？所以你身处一个叫做“演播空间”的巨大空旷空间里，你可能会有一些搭建好的基础布景来跑上跑下并跳过这个或跳过那个，
down and jump over this or jump over that they all represent parts of Pandora drawn in later like topography of the yes exactly topography so we can do the scene running through an approximation of that landscape and you have a suit on with various I don't know ping pong balls a little receptors receptors and you have a helmet that has two cameras facing you which must be just an awful angle I do it's for the dream for well for a little China ball on a third arm there and then I think there's also one facing the person you are talking to and that's all for what a digital in New Zealand spends I wish I knew the exact time and amount of money but it's like to make an avatar it's it's all CGI it's
它们都代表了潘多拉星球后来绘制出的部分，比如地形——是的，完全正确，地形，所以我们可以边跑边完成穿过该地貌近似物的场景，你身上穿着一套带有各种，我不知道，乒乓球大小的接收器，小接收器，你戴着一个头盔，上面有两个朝向你的摄像头，这角度一定糟透了。确实如此，为了那个，为了第三条手臂上的一个小中国球，然后我想还有一个朝向跟你对话的人，这一切都是为了新西兰的数字王国——我希望我知道准确的时间和金钱数额，但制作一个《阿凡达》大概就是这样，全都是CGI，全都是CGI。
all CGI and and how do you how do you dumb actor question to actor how do you connect to the material when you're just a dumb person dumb person to say Sean is quicker how do you from Sean to Sigourney how do you connect to the material when you're not in the thing and you're not and everybody's dressed like you when you're looking across and you can't probably see them because there's a camera in your face that's why I feel it's like an early theater rehearsal where you just have an empty stage and you've read the script and you know who's playing what and you just are there as actors making the scene work and it's not for any camera it's literally for you know for each other yeah and of course
而且你如何，一个笨演员对另一个笨演员的问题，当你只是个笨人时，你如何与素材产生连接？笨人来问肖恩更快一些。从肖恩到西格妮，当你不在这件事里，当所有人穿得都跟你一样，当你看着对面却可能看不到他们，因为你的脸上正对着一个摄像头时，你如何与素材产生连接？这就是为什么我觉得它就像是一场早期的戏剧排练，你只有一个空舞台，你读过剧本，你知道谁在演什么，你作为演员在那里让这场戏成立，它不是为了任何摄像机，它真的只是为了，你知道的，为了彼此。是的，当然了，
Cameron has about 14 guys hidden around the set doing shots of different people and when Jim and I won't be able to explain this well Jim created a camera for the first avatar which kind of looks like course he's holding a dowser and when you're there you can actually look over at a specific screen and see your roughed out avatar being and and how much taller they are than humans and how they relate to the landscape so that's a kind of very rough guide to go oh I see I'm twice as tall as the boy I like you know in the the next story and then you just you forget about all that and you just work on these beautiful very compelling scenes that Jim Cameron has written about this family so you don't you play a teenager
卡梅隆在片场周围藏了大约14个人来拍摄不同的人的镜头。当吉姆和我——我可能解释不好这个，吉姆为第一部《阿凡达》创造了一个摄像机，它看起来有点像他手里拿着一个探测棒，当你身处其中时，你实际上可以看一眼一个特定的屏幕，看到你的粗剪版阿凡达正在——以及它们比人类高多少，它们如何与地貌产生关联。所以这是一个非常粗略的指南，让你觉得，哦，我看到我比我喜欢的那个男孩高两倍，你知道的，在接下来的故事中，然后你把这一切都抛在脑后，你只是致力于这些由吉姆·卡梅隆写关于这个家庭的精美、非常引人入胜的场景，所以你不——你在这部电影里演了一个青少年或者别的什么角色吗？我演了。太疯狂了。
in this one or something at some point I do crazy yeah she said are you listening Sean you know it's called an imagination you should look into it and because she has obviously a very vivid one and she doesn't need all your tiktoks to get inspired now have you seen have you been able to see all the stuff that he said will eventually be wrapped around you i.e. what your character looks like what the world looks like have you seen a rough cut of it or will you see it when we all see it because it takes so long to finish he is taking long time to edit it down to three hours because of course he has a lot of material so I'll see it when we go to the is it called a royal premiere maybe one of the royals
是的，她说。你在听吗，肖恩？你知道这叫想象力，你应该去了解一下。而且因为她显然有一个非常生动的想象力，她不需要你所有的抖音视频来获得灵感。现在你见过他所说的最终会包裹在你身上的东西了吗？即你的角色看起来如何，世界看起来如何，你看过粗剪版吗，还是说等我们大家都看到时你才会看到，因为完成它需要太长的时间，他花了很长时间把它剪辑成三个小时，因为他当然有很多素材。所以当我去参加——是叫皇家首映吗？也许某个皇室成员会想来看它。我们在伦敦开启宣传之旅，所以我们得看看是查尔斯王子、威廉王子还是查尔斯国王——查尔斯国王，是的。
will want to come see it we start the promotional tour in London so we'll have to see if it's Prince Charles Prince William King Charles King Charles yes well there goes a royal premiere we can cut that part out so go on yes please get things are safe but wait anyway so I will see it when when the world sees it wow I do want to ask you because I've never met you just just a couple questions about alien I know you probably do you remember meeting him back so he wants to get back to that I'm sorry he's probably forgotten he has that wait I just want to ask you something like alien or avatar or something I was wonder with actors like you in massive franchises are you as these guys are gonna go nuts are you as into
好吧，皇家首映泡汤了，我们可以把那部分剪掉。所以继续吧——是的，请确保事情安全。但不管怎样，所以当全世界看到它时我就会看到它。哇，我真的想问你，因为我从来没见过你，只需几个关于《异形》的问题。我知道你可能——他想回到那个话题。对不起，他可能忘了，他有那个——等等，我只是想问你一些像《异形》或《阿凡达》之类的事。我想知道对于像你这样出演巨型特许经营权电影的演员来说，你们是否像这些家伙一样会抓狂，你们是否同样沉迷于
the mythology and like the back stories and science of it all as we as the audience are or do you really just think of it as a job you're focusing on your character or you kind or do you get into it at all you know I kind of treat them all the same yeah it's just the script I'm on this you know when I first did alien I couldn't understand why I was working in such beautiful sets and when I wasn't on I could roam through this world and I remember thinking it's so nice of Ridley and Fox to create these worlds that we can just walk through when we're off camera and feel like we're still on the planet I thought they did it for us and I was very touched by that and then of course I realized this over the camera
那些神话、背景故事以及所有的科学设定，作为观众的我们都在——还是说你真的只是把它当作一份工作，专注于你的角色，或者你根本不会深入其中？你知道的，我对待它们的方式其实都差不多，是的，这只是我接的一部剧本。你知道，我刚拍《异星奇兵》时，我不明白为什么要在这么漂亮的布景里工作，不用拍的时候我可以在这个世界里四处闲逛。我记得当时想，雷德利和福克斯太好了，创造了这些世界，让我们在镜头外时可以随便走走，感觉自己好像还在那个星球上。我以为他们是为我们做的，我对此非常感动。然后当然了，我意识到这是为了镜头
but the truth is is that you have done some really iconic science fiction work and maybe Sean is wondering is that is that just did you gravitate towards that or did it just find you in other words do you have like a passion for science fiction no I'm cast excellent I was on a short list for Ripley and I told Ridley I didn't like the script and I got the part I want to talk about that yeah against your against your better judgment you did it but I will say this let me as a follow-up even though you don't have a sort of a natural draw or whatever it is to science fiction but because you've been part of all these incredibly iconic science fiction pieces do you have a sort of an appreciation for it like over
但事实是，你确实拍过一些非常具有标志性的科幻作品，也许肖恩想知道，这是你情不自禁被它吸引，还是它自然而然找到了你？换句话说，你对科幻作品有什么狂热的喜爱吗？没有，我是被选中的。我是雷普利的候选人之一，我告诉雷德利我不喜欢那个剧本，然后我就得到了这个角色。我想谈谈这个，对，违背了你自己的理智，你还是接了。不过我要说的是，作为一个后续问题，尽管你对科幻没有那种天生的吸引力或别的什么，但因为你参与了所有这些极其标志性的科幻作品，你对它有一种欣赏吗？比如说这么多年
the years have you come to embrace it and appreciate it for what it is absolutely it's an amazing space to work in because it's always in the future and that's it is about you know about being human and what our future is so I think that's why the younger audiences love it it's still relevant you know took me a while I mean listen once you've done all these really a ricocheting around the future I totally get it I love it and especially working with Jim Cameron who is either thinking underwater or out in space you know we're in Alpha Centauri I guess is our our solar system for Pandora no it's fascinating it's fascinating I love it I'm so lucky yeah and Ripley and Ripley is like this iconic character of like sort
下来，你是否开始接受它并欣赏它的价值？当然了，这是一个非常棒的创作空间，因为它总是设定在未来，而这正是关于人类以及我们的未来是什么。所以我想这就是为什么年轻观众喜欢它，因为它依然很有现实意义。你知道，我花了一些时间，我是说，听着，一旦你在未来四处闯荡过之后，我完全明白了，我爱上了它。尤其是跟吉姆·卡梅伦合作，他要么是在思考水下世界，要么是在外太空，我们在阿尔法星系——我猜那是潘多拉星系所在的太阳系。不，这太迷人了，太迷人了，我爱它，我太幸运了。雷普利，雷普利就像是那种标志性的角色，某种
of the embodiment of sort of like toughness and kind of grit and somebody who's you know do you do you wear that well do you do you like am I like that no I scream at a spider no I wasn't gonna ask I didn't mean that I meant more how do you feel when people sort of project that on you or how do you like that mantle do you like it or do you kind of shirk it you know I consider it Ripley's mantle and I try to I feel like I have to then throw that to her I feel that way about Ripley too and in fact about the woman I based Ripley on she's still like that even though she's on earth so I feel like a you know I'm a vessel you know and I was very very lucky to be able to tell these stories I was very
程度上是坚韧和勇气的化身，是个那种……你觉得自己配得上这个形象吗？你喜欢……我是那种人吗？不，我会对着蜘蛛尖叫。我本来不是要问那个，我不是那个意思。我的意思是，当人们把那种形象投射到你身上时，你是什么感觉？或者你喜欢这个光环吗？你喜欢它，还是会刻意回避它？你知道，我认为这是雷普利的光环，我努力……我觉得我必须把它还给她。我对雷普利也有这种感觉，事实上，对于我塑造雷普利时所参考的那位女性也是如此，她即使到了地球上也依然是那样。所以我觉得我只是一个容器，你知道。我很幸运能够讲述这些故事，我很
lucky to have the writers who decided to make the lone survivor a woman it's very lucky to have guys working me who like you know strong women but it was all a commercial decision to make the survivor a woman because they just thought you know story wise no one will ever suspect that that's gonna happen interesting I remember being so was it which which alien was it when when you shaved your head was that that's three that's three was it I just found that so I don't know it's something about that time period or that moment right there it seemed like such an incredibly brave and courageous and forward thing for this huge female movie star actor to do something is you know sort of traditionally unglamorous
幸运能有那些决定让唯一的幸存者是一位女性的编剧。我很幸运能有喜欢坚强女性的男士与我合作。但让幸存者成为女性其实全都是一个商业决定，因为他们只是觉得，从剧情角度来看，没有人会料到会发生这种事。很有趣。我记得当时……是哪一部《异星奇兵》来着？你剃光头的那部是《异星奇兵3》吗？是《异星奇兵3》。我当时觉得……我不知道，那个时期的某种氛围，或者说那个特定的时刻，对于这个知名女性电影明星来说，去做一件传统意义上那么不华丽、
as to like shave your head did it feel more frightening or did it feel like this is something that's that's kind of cool and courageous and let's do it and was it and and and did you do it yourself or tell me about that it was David Fincher yeah he just done Vogue you know and he was asked to do right on a video yeah and and so we were at this meeting with Fincher and some of the suits and it ended and we all got up and someone at Fox probably the head said so David how do you see Ripley and we were on our way out the door and he turned around he said I don't know how do you feel about bald and I said sounds great to me and we just went off and did it no really wow I had a baby and I had
甚至可以说是大胆且勇敢的前卫事情——比如剃光头——你当时觉得更害怕，还是觉得这是一件挺酷、挺勇敢、咱们干吧的事情？而且是……而且是你自己动手的吗？跟我说说那是怎么回事。是大卫·芬奇。他刚拍完《Vogue》杂志的视频，然后有人请他来拍这部电影。所以我们和芬奇还有一些高管开会，会议结束了，我们都站起来，福克斯的一个人——可能是负责人——说：“大卫，你觉得雷普利应该是什么样的？”我们正要出门，他转过身说：“我不知道，你们觉得光头怎么样？”我说：“听起来挺不错的。”然后我们就直接去把它给剃了。真的吗？哇！我当时生了个孩子，我那时
lots of hair then and so I tried to cut it in little because they see black and white I tried to cut it off in little stages so I didn't frighten her you're bald at the same time it's chilly otherwise I think it's a really cool look it's so cool and I mean just what a beautiful look to and that sort of postmodern look to did the studio freak out when they saw the first footage that oh my god they weren't they weren't kidding no I think they were delighted I think I was the one my wig that has to work in the beginning was sort of you know like a dog trying to run off my head and so that was that was the greater concern I think than how I look bald was how I looked with the wig on and did that match
有很多头发，所以我试着一小段一小段地把它剪掉，因为他们拍的是黑白片，我想一小段一小段地剪，这样才不会吓到她。你一边光头，一边觉得挺酷，否则我觉得这造型真的很酷，太酷了。而且那种造型也很美，带有一种后现代的风格。当工作室看到第一版素材时，他们有没有吓坏？天哪，他们没有……他们不是开玩笑的。不，我觉得他们很高兴。我觉得我是那个……我的假发在开始时必须要起作用，结果它就像一只狗一样想从我头上跑掉。所以比起我光头时的样子，大家更担心的反而是我戴着假发时的样子，它是否符合
you know the Ripley we last saw but it wasn't alien your first feature film ever well basically yes yes the first week they had to say really kept saying you know can you stop looking in the camera and I said well I'd love to stop looking in the camera but you keep putting it right in front of me and I just had to ask I asked a couple of the actors I said how do you deal with that you know how do you deal with it right being there and it's right there so but what are the odds I mean my god your first one out of the gate how did that happen you know but it was you have to remember it was a very small budget movie you know it was Ridley Scott's second movie I mean I decided very quickly that I didn't
我们上次看到的雷普利的形象？不过，《异星奇兵》难道不是你的第一部故事片吗？嗯，基本上是的，是的。第一周他们不得不说，雷普利一直在说：“你知道，你能别盯着镜头看吗？”我说：“我很想不盯着镜头看，但你们一直把它怼在我面前。”我只好问，我问了几个演员，我说：“你们是怎么处理这个问题的？你知道，当它就在那里的时候，你是怎么应对的？”因为它就贴在你脸上。但机率有多低啊，天哪，你的第一部作品就是这个。这怎么发生的？你知道，但你必须记住，这是一部预算非常小的电影，你知道，这是雷德利·斯科特的第二部电影。我的意思是，我很快就决定我不需要
have to worry about any of it because it was just like being off off Broadway I just was going to be in a different medium but the stakes were low it was you know it was fantastic story but you know no one even thought about franchises there then maybe and it was all in a state and it was all in a stage too so it was in a small area right it was probably felt really contained and at Sheperton yes how did they how did they find you what being your first movie had you been doing a bunch of television shows or no I had I had gotten my first job at the public theater on a John Guare play where I played a maid who was cleaning the glacier a year before and and I feel very lucky and so you know I'd been meeting I was
为这些担心，因为这就像是在外百老汇演出一样，我只是在换一个媒介而已，但风险很低。这是一个非常棒的故事，但当时甚至没有人想到什么系列电影，而且全都是在棚内拍摄的，所以是在一个小区域里。对，感觉一定非常受局限，是在谢珀顿拍摄的。对。他们是怎么找到你的？既然这是你的第一部电影，你之前演过一堆电视剧吗？没有，我是在公共剧院得到了我的第一份工作，那是演约翰·瓜尔的一部戏剧，一年之前我在里面扮演一个在冰川上打扫卫生的女佣。我觉得自己非常幸运，所以我当时一直在面试，我争取过
up for a Mike Nichols movie I you know I was up for a Bob Fosse movie I hardly had an agent people really didn't know what to do with me and I even was part of this depressing class where actors sat around and thought about how to get agents attention like should you make some chocolates put them in a box sure and you eat them all and then you have your 8x10 underneath that sounds like a classic Shanay's I didn't I didn't do anything like that all the time but I did write what the agent who finally accepted me I wrote something like love Sigourney in parentheses it's a crime that I'm not working weaver was the Bob Fosse film that you read for was it all that jazz I think it was the one with Maryl
迈克·尼科尔斯的电影，我争取过鲍勃·福斯的电影。我几乎没有经纪人，大家真的不知道该拿我怎么办。我甚至还参加过一个令人沮丧的班，演员们坐在那儿琢磨怎么引起经纪人的注意，比如：你该做一些巧克力，把它们装在一个盒子里，当然了，你把它们全吃光，然后把你的8x10照片压在下面？听起来像是肖恩会干的经典桥段。我没有，我可没干过那种事，但我确实写过……那个最后接受我的经纪人，我写了类似这样的话：括号里写着“爱你们的西格妮”，后面写着“我不工作简直是个罪过”韦弗。你试镜的那个鲍勃·福斯电影是《爵士春秋》吗？我想是和玛丽尔
Hemingway 1981 or yeah one of those star 80 star 80 yeah you know when I was in just a little sidebar thing and when I was in high school I watched I saw you in gorillas in the mist and you were like amazing and after that movie because the trailer would keep running on TV all the time I mean the commercial for it and so my go-to joke as a kid to anyone that was bothering me or teasing me was your line from gorillas in the mist which was get off my mountain I would say that all the time I love it I'm gonna use that it's much more fun to say than get away from her you bitch you know my mountain still works yeah there must have been there must have been in that time a lot of are there any films from that
海明威合作的那部，1981年还是……对，就是那些星光熠熠的电影。你知道，当我还在上高中时——这算是一个小插曲——我看了《迷雾中的大猩猩》，你在里面棒极了。看完那部电影后，因为它的预告片一直在电视上播个不停，我是说它的商业广告。所以作为小屁孩的我，对任何烦我或者逗我的人用的万能笑话，就是你在《迷雾中的大猩猩》里的台词：“从我的山上滚开！”我老是这么说。我太喜欢了，我要用这个。这比“从她身边滚开，你这个碧池”好玩多了！“我的山上”这句现在还管用。对，那个时期一定有……有很多电影……
era that we all that you regret passing on or not doing that yeah that at the time you thought I can't get my head around this or I don't get it and then later you went I wish I'd been able to get my head around that there are a couple of you know in the 70s and 80s there were a lot of what I would call male fantasy movies like body heat in place those were quite common that kind of and I just didn't get them I just felt that if I couldn't relate to the character and if there was not much character to relate to I would have been too insecure to just try to look good and sound fascinating because I don't think I'm charming enough to to maintain that kind of focus if I don't believe in what I'm doing
那个时代有没有什么电影是你后悔错过或者没去拍的？当时你觉得“我无法理解这个”或者“我搞不懂”，然后后来你才想“我要是当时能理解就好了”。有一些……你知道，在70和80年代，有很多我称之为“男性幻想电影”的作品，比如《体热》和《油脂》。这些电影相当常见，那种类型的。而我就是无法理解它们。我只是觉得，如果我无法与这个角色产生共鸣，而且也没有太多角色可供共鸣的话，我会太缺乏安全感，以至于无法仅仅靠让自己看起来不错、声音迷人去撑场面，因为我觉得我没有足够的魅力去维持那种专注度，如果我自己都不相信我在做什么的话。
and that that's just me I just couldn't relate to it and speaking of that like because a lot of your character do you do you ever include yourself in the process of writing with the writer or do you ever kind of like change some dialogue to fit your vision of the character because it just seems like something you might be interested in or do because it's so everything you say it seems so real and honest oh well that's very nice of you yeah that is I guess our job the only time I've really contributed stuff like that is when the script does not continue to be good and then survival and then it's cutting and rewriting a little so you can manage yeah very diplomatically put by the way most people would be like yeah
那就只是我个人而已，我就是无法对它产生共鸣。说到这个……因为你的很多角色……你有没有在创作过程中参与过编剧的写作，或者你会不会为了契合你对角色的理解而修改一些对白？因为这听起来像是你会感兴趣的事，或者是因为你说的每一句话听起来都那么真实、真诚？哦，那真是太谢谢你了。对，那确实是我们的工作。我真正贡献这种内容的时候，只有在剧本质量开始下降的时候，为了生存，然后就是进行删减和微调，好让它说得过去。对。顺便说一句，说得非常外交辞令。大多数人会说：“哦，那个剧本太烂了，我把整个第二幕都重写了。”你的丈夫也是圈内人吗？吉姆在市中心经营了20年的跳蚤剧院。
that script was terrible and I rewrote the whole second act is your is your husband in the business Jim ran the flea theater for 20 years downtown got you he's an absolutely amazing director yeah and I feel very fortunate since we hardly knew each other when we got married that I had I ended up marrying someone who totally got what I did respected the time it took really enjoys working with me on the occasional script we have to be right or just working on working on you know I can run lines with him we talk about stuff so I like to hit the ground running I have the same relationship actually that's great with her husband with her husband yeah yeah does she know I'm I'm revealing it right now we'll be right back
原来如此！他是一位非常了不起的导演。对，我感到非常幸运，因为我们结婚时其实对彼此还不是很了解，但我最后嫁给了一个完全理解我的工作、尊重它所需要的时间、并且非常喜欢和我一起琢磨偶尔需要修改的剧本的人，或者只是……只是讨论工作。我可以跟他对台词，我们讨论各种事情，所以我喜欢一开始就火力全开。实际上，我和她的丈夫……我和她的丈夫有着同样的合作关系。是吗？她知道我在大庭广众之下说出来了吗？我们马上回来。
spotless is sponsored by better help boy does life not come with a user manual I know it's something that I've talked about before there are so many times in my life where I wish it did though come with a user manual I'm 52 I know thank you very much but the truth is there have been so many moments that I've had to navigate over the years and what's funny is you think that as you get older you get wiser but sometimes that's not necessarily the case and sometimes as you get older it's just things get more complicated and I have found whether it's issues with with family or issues that I've kind of let build up with me what having to do with anxiety and you know needing to talk to somebody about it
《Spotless》由 BetterHelp 赞助。天哪，生活怎么会没有一本使用说明书呢？我知道，这是我以前谈论过的事情，在我生命中有太多次，我希望它真的有一本使用说明书。我52岁了，我知道，非常感谢。但事实是，这些年来我不得不经历的时刻实在太多了。有趣的是，你以为随着年龄的增长你会变得更聪明，但有时情况并非如此。有时随着年龄的增长，事情只是变得更加复杂。我发现，无论是家庭问题，还是我让它在自己体内积压的有关焦虑的问题，以及需要找人倾诉这些事情……
therapy has just been an unbelievable outlet for me and been so valuable in letting go of a lot of things and helping move through difficult times so like I said life doesn't come with a user manual but when it's not working for you you know it's it's just it's really normal to feel stuck and therapists are trained to help you figure out those stuck moments and help you figure out the the cause of challenging emotions and learn productive coping skills and figure out ways through difficult times which makes therapy the closest thing to a guided tour of the complex engine called you so I'm I'm really really lucky I can't advocate enough the idea of talking to somebody talking to a therapist and you
心理治疗对我来说简直是一个不可思议的宣泄口，在放下许多事情以及帮助度过艰难时期方面具有极高的价值。就像我说的，生活没有使用说明书，但当它对你不起作用时，你知道，感到困惑是非常正常的。而治疗师经过专业培训，可以帮你理清那些陷入困境的时刻，帮你找出那些充满挑战的情绪的根源，并学习富有成效的应对技巧，找到度过艰难时期的途径。这使得心理治疗最接近于由导游带领、游览名为“你自己”这座复杂机器的旅程。所以，我真的、真的很幸运。我怎么强调都不为过：找个人聊聊，找个治疗师聊聊，并
know help you navigate moments that are really tricky as the world's largest therapy service better help has matched three million people with professionally licensed vetted therapists available 100% online plus it's very affordable just fill out a brief questionnaire to match with a therapist and if things aren't clicking you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime be honestly it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no endless searching for the right therapist learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartlist that's better help H-E-L-P.com slash smartlist Our thanks to G4 for supporting smartlist let me just say Jason is going to be very
借助他们的帮助来度过那些非常棘手的时刻。作为全球最大的心理治疗服务机构，BetterHelp 已经为300万名用户匹配了拥有专业执照、经过严格审核的治疗师，且完全100%在线提供服务。此外，它非常实惠，只需填写一份简短的问卷即可匹配到治疗师。如果感觉不对劲，你随时可以轻松更换新治疗师。说实话，这再简单不过了——没有候诊室，没有交通拥堵，不用无休止地寻找合适的治疗师。在 BetterHelp.com/smartlist 了解更多信息，并在首月享受九折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp点com斜杠 smartlist。感谢 G4 对 SmartLess 的支持。我必须说，杰森会对
jealous about this one because this is a brand that he loves and I know they love him but I also love this brand because they make some pretty dope stuff add color to your game with G4 you'll find men's and women's apparel footwear and golf accessories all available at G4.com G4's holiday gift guide features a limited edition capsule collection of on and off course items available while supplies last okay so G4 this great golf brand that also makes off course stuff I just got a brand new golf bag from G4 it's like leather and it's got like this kind of crisscross design on it it's got like a red stripe on it and it's a shoulder bag I can carry it it's got my name on it it's amazing but it's this beautiful
这个赞助商非常嫉妒，因为这是一个他深爱的品牌，我也知道他们深爱着他。但我也同样热爱这个品牌，因为他们制造了一些相当酷炫的产品。穿上 G4，为你的运动增添色彩。你可以在 G4.com 找到男士和女士服饰、鞋履以及高尔夫配饰。G4 的节日礼品指南主打一个限量版的精选胶囊系列，涵盖场上和场外单品，售完即止。好了，所以 G4 这个伟大的高尔夫品牌，同时也生产场外服饰。我刚刚从 G4 买了一个全新的高尔夫球包，它是皮革材质的，上面有一种交叉的设计，带有一条红色的条纹，而且是一个单肩包，我可以背着它，上面还印着我的名字，太棒了。它是一个漂亮的
black leather bag it's really lightweight but very sort of durable and cool and it's got the G4 logo on it it's so they make such great stuff I also have some G4 golf shoes I have G4 golf gloves they make awesome stuff and the Gallivanter golf shoe is very popular and boasts a traditional silhouette with modern performance properties it's got do you like optimal traction pattern check massaging and washable insoles check anti microbial mesh lining for no break in period check waterproof designs check a lot of checks plus you'll get complimentary shipping on all standard speed orders check out their site and order soon to ensure your gifts are delivered before the holidays by going to gfore.com slash smartlist
黑色皮质包，非常轻便，但又极其耐用、酷炫，上面还有 G4 的标志。他们制造的产品质量实在是太高了。我还拥有一些 G4 的高尔夫鞋、G4 的高尔夫手套，他们制造的东西太棒了。其中的 Gallivanter 高尔夫球鞋非常受欢迎，拥有传统的鞋型轮廓以及现代的性能属性。它具备了吗？最佳抓地力纹路——有。按摩且可水洗鞋垫——有。抗菌网眼衬里，无需磨合期——有。防水设计——有。有太多的优点了。此外，所有标准速度订单均可享受免费配送服务。快去他们的网站下单，确保你的礼物在节日前送达。访问 gfore.com/smartlist，
to get 10% off your first order today that's gfore.com slash smartlist smartlist gets support from Viori clothing with the holidays coming up you know Viori pieces are pretty awesome for for gifts I've talked a lot about my core shorts which I love which I wear all the time and I implore you to wear them as well because they're great for working out they're also great for hanging out I got this real great Viori jacket I liked it so much in the green I also got it in the black it's like this casual kind of lightweight jacket oh man it just looks so good it's just got this like sort of like classic design and you can kind of wear it anywhere you could wear it with jeans you can wear it with a pair of pants
今天首单即可享受九折优惠。网址是 gfore.com/smartlist。SmartLess 获得 Viori 服装的大力支持。随着假期的临近，你知道 Viori 的单品作为礼物是相当棒的选择。我经常谈论我的 Core 短裤，我太喜欢它们了，我一直在穿，我恳求你们也去穿它们，因为它们不仅非常适合锻炼，也很适合闲逛。我有一件 Viori 的夹克，我太喜欢这个绿色了，所以我又买了一件黑色的。这是一种休闲的、轻量化的夹克，天哪，它看起来太棒了。它有一种经典的设计风格，你几乎可以把它穿去任何地方。你可以搭配牛仔裤，可以搭配长裤，
you can wear it to dinner blah blah blah here's the thing if you're tired of traditional old workout gear you got to check out Viori their product is incredibly versatile it can be used for just about any activity like running or training or swimming or yoga but it's also great for lounging or weekend errands or meeting friends for brunch or going antiquing which I'm sure some of you do or even if you're just driving around aimlessly you know trying to make a friend everything they make is designed to look great in everyday life outside the gym so again like I said I got my core short I wear it I work out then I got to hop in the car I got to go get some gas for the car I got to go to the store to buy get some food
可以穿去吃晚饭，等等等等。事情是这样的，如果你厌倦了传统老旧的锻炼装备，你一定要去看看 Viori。他们的产品具有难以置信的多功能性，几乎可以用于任何活动，比如跑步、训练、游泳或瑜伽，但也非常适合闲逛、周末跑腿、和朋友吃早午餐、去逛古董店（我确信你们当中有些人会这么做），甚至哪怕你只是漫无目的地开车兜风（你知道，试图去结交个朋友）。他们制造的所有东西都旨在让人们在健身房之外的日常生活中看起来也很棒。所以就像我说的，我穿着我的 Core 短裤，锻炼完后，我不得不跳上车，去给汽车加点油，去商店买点食物，
I got to pick up this I got to take the kids over to a friend's I got to do all this stuff guess what y'all I'm still in the core shorts and that's not a secret because I'm going wide with that Viori is 100% offsetting their carbon footprint as well they are also reducing and offsetting 100% of their plastic footprint from 2019 and beyond they're utilizing better sustainable materials for their products empowering your best active life feel good about the things you buy and also how they're made Viori is an investment in your happiness for our listener they're offering 20% off your first purchase get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartlist that's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash
我得去取这个，我得把孩子们带到一个朋友家，我得做所有这些事情。大家猜怎么着？我仍然穿着那条 Core 短裤！这并不是什么秘密，因为我正在大方地展示它。Viori 还在 100% 抵消他们的碳足迹。他们还在减少和抵消 2019 年及以后 100% 的塑料足迹。他们正在为产品利用更好的可持续材料，赋能你最积极健康的生活。为你购买的东西以及它们的制造方式感到安心。Viori 是对你幸福感的一笔投资。为我们的听众提供首单八折优惠。在 Viori.com/smartlist 购买地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装。网址是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠
smartlist not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase but enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns go to Viori.com slash smartlist and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. And now back to the show. Let's get back to you guys got married before you knew each other this was sort of an arranged thing we're making news today you guys. Well I was older and I went to the Williamstown Theater Festival and on the very first day I was there I saw this cute guy chain smoking in the student union in front of like a stack
smartlist。你不仅可以获得首单八折优惠，还可以享受任何美国境内订单满 75 美元的免运费和免费退货服务。访问 Viori.com/smartlist，探索 Viori 服装的多功能性。现在，让我们回到节目中。让我们回到你们俩在不了解彼此的情况下就结婚了，这算是一种包办婚姻吗？我们今天可是在爆猛料啊，各位。好吧，我当时年纪大一点，我去了威廉斯敦戏剧节。在那里的第一天，我就看到这个可爱的家伙在学生会大楼里抽着连环烟，面前堆着一叠契诃夫的书，然后我心想：“天哪，那是我吗？”然后我并没有真正跟他说话，而在……等等，那是你的策略吗？你打算……你打算冷落他一会儿吗？
of books on check off and I went oh boy was it me and then I didn't really speak to him and at the end of wait was that your strategy you were gonna you were gonna kind of ignore him a little bit no it was Diane Wiest and I were in a pinter play on the main stage and Jim was sort of directing the the non-ex the non-equity kids and you know he ran the bar and this guy sounds really hot you know he he looked like a player and I thought he's not for me right yeah I don't need that and so then at the end of the summer I was sitting at the sort of party next to Diane Wiesty and I said see that guy over there across the room I saw him the first day I'm gonna go over and ask him to dance and she went
不，当时黛安·韦斯特和我正在主舞台上排演一出品特的戏剧，而吉姆当时在导演那些非演员协会的孩子们。你知道的，他经营着酒吧，然后这家伙听起来真的很辣，你知道的，他看起来像个风流浪子，我心想：“他可不是我的菜，对吧？我不需要那种麻烦。”所以到了夏天结束的时候，我坐在派对上，挨着黛安·韦斯特坐着。我说：“看到那边房间对面的那个家伙了吗？我第一天就看到他了，我要走过去请他跳舞。”她大喊：“哦，去吧，齐吉，去吧！”因为我们俩那个夏天都是单身，我们谈论的全部内容就像是……你知道的，借用你传记的名字：去吧，齐吉，去吧！所以你走过去，你溜达过去……我们就去吧。好吧，也许……也许我是试着溜达过去的。我走到那个正和朋友站在一起的家伙面前，我说：“嗨，你想跳舞吗？”他回答：“不想。”我当时的感觉就像是：现在我得穿过整个房间走回去。我只记得自己朝黛安的方向走去，每过一秒钟我都恨不得贴地而行。他追上了我，他说：“非常对不起，我当然想跟你跳舞。”但我没法看他，我已经被彻底打击了。几个月后，我举办了一场万圣节方块舞生日
oh go Ziggy go because we both were unattached that summer and all we talked about was like you know just by the name of your biography go Ziggy go and so you walk over so you go over there you saunter over let's go well maybe maybe I tried to saunter I got up to the guy who was standing with his friends and I said hi you want to dance and he went no and I just was like now I have to get across the room so I just remember going toward Diane kind of you know getting closer to the ground every second he caught up with me and he said I'm so sorry of course I want to dance with you but I couldn't look at him I had been deflated so entirely and then months later I had a Halloween square dance birthday
派对，那时我们开始拍摄《捉鬼敢死队》。我翻看了宾客名单，心想：“好吧，再给他一次机会。”他来了，而且玩得很开心，尽管他谁也不认识。大约两个月后，我们决定结婚。我们已经结婚38年了。这真的很酷。我想部分原因在于你们并没有整天黏在一起。我经常外出拍摄另一部《异星奇兵》或者别的什么。不，他太棒了，他来自夏威夷，浑身充满着阿洛哈精神。他就是……我太幸运了，你知道的。这太不可思议了。你们俩有没有决定要孩子，还是说事情太忙了？不，我们有一个可爱的女儿。对，现在32岁了。我不知道为什么她看起来依然像12岁。不过，好吧，她有这么糟糕的基因，
party when we started shooting Ghostbusters and I I went through the book and I thought all right give him another try again and he came and he had such a good time even though he didn't know anyone and about two months later we decided to get married we've been married 38 years that's really cool I think part of it is that you're not with each other all the time I was often away filming another alien or something but no he's so great he's from Hawaii he's filled with Aloha he's just I'm so lucky you know that's amazing did you guys ever decided to have kids or things just too busy no we have a wonderful daughter yeah is now 32 I don't know how she still looks 12 but well she's got such terrible genes you
你知道的。她也进演艺圈了吗？她当老师。哦，对，太棒了！事实上，他们是非二元性别者，他们教……我明白了。不是表演，是学术，对，数字讲故事和角色构建之类的事情。哦，太棒了，太棒了！多酷的一个家庭啊！对，非常酷的家庭。你知道，我们可能会给人那种印象，但其实并没有。我是说，肖恩整天都在看电视、吃酸面奇趣糖，你们本可以拥有其中一个的，你知道的。真的，然后循环播放你所有的电影。你可能觉得我在开玩笑，但如果有你的话我们会非常高兴的，绝对的。不过说到婚礼，是不是你当的主婚人？因为你和我一样热爱狗，我想我们大家都有养狗，对吧？
know did she go into the business as well she teaches oh right yeah amazing in fact they're non-binary and they teach a gotcha not not acting academics yes digital storytelling and role-building and things like that oh that's awesome that's awesome what a cool family yeah very cool family you know we may give that impression but no I mean Sean watches TV and eats sour patch kids all day you could have had one of those you know true and just watch all your movies on a loop and you think I'm kidding but we would have been delighted to have you absolutely but but speaking of weddings didn't you officiate because you love dogs as much as I do I think we all own dogs yeah right and didn't you officiate a dog wedding
没错。你是不是曾经给一场狗狗婚礼当过主婚人什么的？来吧！是的，是的。我们的女儿当时10岁，我们决定给我们的那只小型意大利灵缇犬配种。查尔说：“如果她要生小狗，她就得结婚。”我说：“当然啦。”所以我们准备了花瓣，准备了一件我们在 Zidamers 买的漂亮婚纱。我们有新郎，我们有一个伴郎把新郎带了进来。查尔是牧师，我们甚至还有一份“婚前狗协议”。哇！而且还有……我必须说，它们看起来确实相当相爱。然后在蜜月期间，它们却怎么也搞不清怎么凑到一块去。我听说……好吧，我听说它们爪子一刻也离不开对方。顺便说一句，大笑的家伙们，太蠢了，管它呢！不管怎样，现在我们实际上……在新冠疫情期间，我们……那两只狗狗很久以前就已经安息了，现在我们有一只可爱的小型意大利灵缇犬，名叫科西·范·图蒂（Così fan tutte），因为她是一只意大利灵缇犬，莫扎特的歌剧，对吧？带个G，对，科西·范……没错，肖恩，谢谢你，肖恩，接得好！等一下，我想知道，在让你离开之前，关于《阿凡达》还有几件事。现在，当你们拍摄时，有没有讨论过把它们全部同时拍摄？或者你们……这更像是一个贝特曼式的问题：你们是不是签约要拍完所有的部分，所以你们不能接其他工作，必须保持全职待命？你是说全部五部吗？对，对。
once or something come on yes yes our our daughter was 10 yeah and we decided to breed our little Italian greyhound and char said well if she's going to have babies she has to get married and I said well absolutely so we had pedals in a little beautiful wedding dress that we bought at Zidamers we had the groom we had a best man who brought the groom in char was the minister we had a pre-pup-tual agreement wow and we had it was covers and I must say they seemed quite in love and then the honeymoon they couldn't figure out how to get together I heard well I heard they couldn't keep their paws off each other by the way laughing guys dumbest shit anyway so now we have actually in during COVID we we did those two dogs are
曾经还是怎么的，来吧，对，对，我们女儿当时10岁，对，我们决定让我们那只小型意大利灵缇犬配种，查尔说，好吧，如果她要生小狗，她就得结婚，我说，当然啦，所以我们让佩德尔穿上了一件我们在齐达默斯买的小巧漂亮的婚纱，我们有新郎，我们有一个把新郎带上台的伴郎，查尔是牧师，我们有一份婚前协议，哇，我们有，那是，而且我必须说他们看起来非常相爱，然后是蜜月，他们不知道怎么才能在一起，我听说，嗯，我听说他们爪子总是不离对方，顺便说一句，笑着，伙计们，最蠢的事，不管怎样，现在我们实际上在疫情期间，我们，我们养了那两只狗是
rested in peace long ago and now we have a little a beautiful little Italian greyhound named cosy fang tutti because she is an Italian greyhound the Mozart opera yes with a G yeah cosy fang that's right Sean thanks yeah Sean good that was a good catch wait so I want to know it's more just a few more things about avatar before we let you go yeah now when you guys so was there talk about filming them all at the same time are you guys this is like more of a Bateman question are you guys contract contracted to do all of them so you cannot do other work you have to remain available full fight you mean all five yeah yeah like you have to block out the next five years of your life did they pay for first position go ahead sick or
就像你必须把未来五年的生活时间都空出来一样，他们会付首选档期的片酬吗？说吧，西格……或者……我不知道，但我只是好奇，想了解一下：为了那个系列，你现在必须让自己随时待命，持续（五年、六年、七年、八年、九年）？肖恩这里有一个独幕剧，他很希望你能读一下。所以第二部要上映了，对吧？两年后，第三部可能会上映。可能在第三部之后，当吉姆想象着在创造了更多潜水艇之后再回到这个项目时，我们将开始拍摄第四部和第五部，我们会把它们放在一起拍，然后它们最终会上映。所以最后一部将在28年上映，到那时我大概会拄着拐杖走路了。拍每一部需要花多长时间？嗯，我想我断断续续工作了一年半，但我想吉姆可能……他必须拍摄真人实景部分，也就是和演员一起拍，
yeah I don't know but I was just curious like to know like do you have to keep yourself now available for that franchise for you know five six seven eight nine Sean has a one act he'd love for you to read so two's coming out yeah two years three will come out probably after three when Jim can imagine going back to this after you know creating a few more submarines we will start four and five and we will shoot them together and then eventually they will come out so the last one will come out in 28 where I'll be you know walking the cane and how long does it take to shoot each one well I think I was on it working regularly a year and a half but I think Jim probably he had to do the live action which is with actors
那又是一年半的时间。所以我敢肯定，光是拍摄就要花大约三年时间。与此同时，你知道的，后期制作大约需要五年时间来转换。哇，所以这是一个极其庞大的……不，我没有……他们必须围绕我的日程来安排。原来如此。你在哪里拍这个？是在曼哈顿海滩进行表演捕捉，然后在纽西兰拍摄真人部分。现在，去外百老汇来个轻松愉快的短周期演出，或者回到威廉斯敦，听起来是不是要好管理得多？我的意思是，如果我们把其中一个项目塞进这些拍摄的中间，会不会……好吧，我确实……我真的需要去光谱的另一端，去拍一些小成本电影。我今年也有大约三部小成本电影要上映，它们让我保持理智。
you see that was another year and a half so I'm sure it caught it's like three three years to just shoot it and meanwhile what it takes about five years to trans you know transform it wow so it is a big colossal no I have no they have to work around my schedule yeah there you go where do you do that it's in Manhattan Beach for the performance capture and and then in New Zealand for the live action now it doesn't a nice quick run off Broadway or going back to Williamstown doesn't that sound a little bit more manageable I mean what if we slide one of those like right in the middle of one of these well I do I do try to obviously you really need to you know go to the opposite end of the spectrum
对。所以我们看了……请允许我说，我们绝对是《黑钱胜地》的狂热粉丝，这部剧太吓人了，你们在里面的表现太惊艳了。但我有一个建议。哦？噢，这个好。我们在大结局时锁定了结局……我猜那本该是你的女儿，因为我们假设她逃过了这一切，她可能会过上正常的生活，也许吧？如果她杀了他的话，我们就会想：“天哪，所有人都要卷入其中了！”我觉得……我觉得很多人都会同意你的看法。西格妮的结局会好得多。威廉·戈德曼已经写过一本书了，书名叫《黑钱胜地本可以更好》。我很抱歉，我不是那个意思……不，你知道的，我懂你，这是一个伟大的剧组，我们都觉得……我……有趣的是，我给他发了一封电子邮件，里面就是这个完全相同的建议。总之，西格妮，我们占用你太多时间了。我们爱你，谢谢你能来，你决定做这件事真是太酷了！
and do small you know I've done about three small movies that are all coming out this year too and and they they keep me sane yeah so we watched may I just say I we were just devotees of Ozark which was so terrifying guys were so amazing in it but I have one suggestion uh-oh yeah this is good we are locked at the very end yeah I think it should have been your daughter because we assume that she's escaped all of this and she might have a normal life maybe right and if she had killed him we would have gone oh my god everyone is gonna be in this I think I think a lot of people agree with you security would have been way better William Goldman's already written a book about it it's called how Ozark could
而且拍一些小电影，你知道的，我今年也有大约三部小电影要上映，它们让我保持清醒，是的，所以我们看了——请允许我直说，我们简直是《黑钱胜地》的忠实粉丝，那部剧太吓人了，你们在里面的表现太棒了，但我有个建议，哦噢，太好了，我们在最后关头被锁定了，是的，我觉得应该是你女儿，因为我们以为她已经逃脱了这一切，她可能会过上正常的生活，对吧，如果她杀了韦德，我们会想，天哪，所有人都要卷入其中了，我想很多人都会同意你的看法，安全性会好得多，威廉·戈德曼已经写过一本关于这个的书了，书名叫《黑钱胜地将如何》
have been better I'm sorry I don't mean that to be no you know I'm with you it's a great group we all thought I you know it's a funny I emailed him that exact same suggestion but anyway Sigourney we've taken up too much of your time we love you thank you for being here it's so cool you decided to do this yes well I'm so grateful to you for thinking of me and I we love your show and you guys are awesome and I love the way you do ads too oh yeah we gotta do some of those today I think I wanted to do an ad for you you want to yeah why don't you do it no no I don't have one text or just what about a hey hey buckle up here comes a new uh smart yes yes yes that you do an intro oh my gosh yeah we
嗯，我很感激你们能想到我，我们都爱你们的节目，你们棒极了。而且我也很喜欢你们做广告的方式！哦，对，我们今天得做几个那样的广告。我想让你做个广告，你想做吗？要不你来做？不，我没有台词，或者……“嘿，系好安全带，这里来了一个全新的 SmartLess！”你来做一个开场白？哦，天哪！对，我们应该做一个开场白，就说类似的话。好啊，不用照本宣科，做你自己就好，我们玩得开心点。准备好了，开始录音。自我介绍一下，然后介绍节目。好啊……嗯，你今天是谁？那边是谁？我是西格妮·韦弗，我只想说：嘿，系好安全带，这里来了一个全新的 SmartLess！谢谢你，西格妮！谢谢你们大家，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。爱你，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。多好……多好的一种开始一天的方式啊！哦，天哪！对，我的意思是，说真的，谁不会在刷屏幕的时候……我可以看《异星奇兵》一直坐着看。好吧，每次西格妮·韦弗……我没有不小心说出“我一生都爱着她”吧？那句话没说出口吧？你没说出来，那句话停留在心里了。太好了！
should do an intro and just that something like that yeah you don't make it make it your own just let's just have fun with it here we go rolling introduce yourself and then introduce the show yeah hey um who are you today who is that over there I'm Sigourney weaver and I just want to say hey buckle up here comes a new smartness thank you Sigourney thank you guys so much thank you thank you thank you thank you love you bye bye bye bye what a what a what a pleasant way to start the day oh my gosh yeah I mean I truly who doesn't when you're scrolling through the thing I can see aliens on just sit and watch it all right every time Sigourney weaver is I didn't accidentally say I've been in love with her my entire life
应该做一个开场白，就这样，类似这样的，对，不要拘泥，发挥你自己的风格，我们在这儿玩得开心点，开始吧，录音中，介绍一下你自己，然后再介绍这个节目，对，嘿，嗯，你今天是哪位，那边那是谁，我是西格妮·韦弗，我只想说，嘿，系好安全带，全新的聪慧来了，谢谢你，西格妮，非常感谢你们，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，爱你们，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，以多么多么多么愉快的方式开始新的一天，哦天哪，是的，我的意思是，真的，谁不会呢，当你浏览那个东西时，我能看到《异星战场》，就坐着看，好吧，每次西格妮·韦弗出现，我不是不小心说的，我这辈子一直都爱着她
did I that didn't come out you did not stayed internal great did you did you I think about all the movies we could have talked about go we didn't even talk about Ghostbusters no I know and that's and that was probably on purpose my because that that's where it really started for me I know and you know because obviously who you're going to call well I guess oh it will by the way I did want to mention to her because somebody once accused me and she needs to know I ain't afraid of no ghost okay well he just did it again oh no but I wish that I let her know no ghost okay no well you're really you're really I'm adamant your conviction yeah I'm adamant about it but you know would you when you guys
你有没有……我想着所有我们本可以聊的电影，我们甚至都没聊《Ghostbusters》（捉鬼敢死队）！不，我知道，而且这可能是有意为之的，因为……因为那才是我真正开始的地方。我懂，而且你知道，因为很显然，“你该打电话给谁？”好吧，我猜……哦，顺便说一句，我确实想对她提一下，因为曾经有人指控我——她需要知道——我不怕鬼，好吧！噢，他又来了一次。哦，不！但我希望我能让她知道……“我不怕鬼，好吧！”不，好吧，你的态度真的很坚决。我很坚定，我有这个信念。对，我很坚定。但是你知道，当你们节目上有那种你们是超级粉丝的人时，你们难道不会有点害怕去问他们关于那些让他们成名的事情吗？因为你们觉得他们已经厌倦了谈论这些？但对，但你还是挺想知道的，对吧？
have people like that on that you're super fans of aren't you kind of afraid to ask them about you know the things that made them famous because you think they're just sick of talking about it but yeah but you kind of want to know right well yeah that's that's what that's our little sort of like gift our little privilege we're so lucky to be able to just say hey excuse me sir can I see a question yeah exactly yeah I love that Jason you always want to know like schedule and you always want to know do you get Fridays like what did you do how did you get out you're always looking for the out you get portal to portal right or you know there's a show there's a show called I don't know if I think
好吧，对，那是我们的一个小小的特权，我们太幸运了，能够直接说：“嘿，打扰一下，先生，我可以问个问题吗？”完全是这样。我喜欢这样。杰森，你总是想知道档期，你总是想问：“你们周五能休息吗？你是怎么做的？你是怎么脱身的？”你总是在寻找退路。你是可以点对点接送的，对吧？或者你知道，有一个节目——我不知道，我想它可能在 Netflix 上，叫作《电影的诞生》（The Movies That Made Us），你知道这个节目吗？不知道。它讲的全都是那些标志性的电影，他们会找一些参与过制作的人来谈论它，而且他们还播放了从来没人看过的幕后花絮。其中一期就是《异星奇兵》，我大概一个月前刚看过。我本来想跟她聊聊这个，关于所有的……那简直是一团糟，每个人都在对彼此大喊大叫，尖叫不断，拍摄还暂停了一段时间，然后他们又回去拍了……我想我刚才怎么没在节目里问她呢？
it's on Netflix maybe it's called the movies that made us do you know this show no and they and it's all these iconic movies and they get some of the people that worked on them to talk about it and they do they have behind the scenes clips nobody's ever seen and one of them was aliens and I just watched it like a month ago and the I wanted to talk to her about it about all of the it was just kind of a mess and everybody was yelling at each other and screaming and it got shut down for a while and then they went back and think I think I didn't ask her when we just had her on the show no I know but I mean what are you doing any other exciting questions you want to ask anybody else hey you got anything
不，我知道，但我的意思是，你还有什么精彩的问题想问别人吗？嘿，你有什么想问达克斯的吗？我们的第一个嘉宾……已经好几百期了，也许你已经积累了一个不错的后续采访问题库。实际上，还有……你们有没有觉得……你们是在时空连续体里找到了一个裂缝吗？怎么你和斯科蒂能找出这么多时间来看所有这些破节目？天哪！我的意思是，到了晚上，你看了多少纪录片之类的东西？我刚看了关于西妮德·奥康娜的那部，我觉得挺不错的。等等，你们总是告诉我——威利，这跟你一天读十本书是一样的。那倒也是，两样我都不干。那我到底忙着干嘛呢？等等，我可以……我可以开始……我刚才根本没在听回应，安静！你知道的，我很想看到亚历克斯从后面的那扇门走进来。是时候让妈妈去客串另一个特别嘉宾了。当你结束了那里的参观、工作之类的事情后，要说“哦，它来了”，说声“拜拜”会不会很难？我觉得我们永远不能直接说……为什么不呢？为什么不呢？太懒了。好吧，事情是这样的，事情是这样的。我的意思是，虽然我很想留在这里，因为我住在这里，我在这里长大，但我搬去了纽约，现在我住在洛杉矶，但我有个地方离这儿不远，所以从技术上讲，我仍然……没那么棒。就像我们已经用过一百万次那个梗了。不，我们可能……顺便说一句，所以我在这里……我是跟我爸在书房里。我爸去了曼尼托巴大学，曼尼托巴……我在这里……我爸的书房……我的父母是……你不需要重来，你不需要重置自己。我们要剪掉它……我们不会剪掉的，我们会保留你重新开始的部分……还在录音呢！
that you want to ask Dax our first guest ever a couple hundred and maybe you worked up a good database of post interview questions actually also did you you guys find like a tear in the space time can do where you and Scotty finding all this time to watch all this shit holy crap I mean at night you watch a lot of your night started on 330 leave how many documentaries and stuff you've seen I just watched the one on Shanae O'Connor I thought that was pretty good wait you guys are always tell me will it's the same as you reading ten books a day that's true I get I do neither what am I so busy doing I got it I can I can I start no I wasn't listening a response at all quiet you know I'd love to see I'd love
你想问我们有史以来的第一位嘉宾达克斯几个问题，也许你已经建立了一个很好的采访后问题数据库，事实上，你们有没有发现时空连续体出现了裂缝，你和斯科特是从哪里挤出这么多时间来看完所有这些破玩意的，天哪，我的意思是晚上你看了很多，你的夜晚从3点30分开始，离开，你到底看过多少纪录片之类的数据，我刚刚看了辛妮·奥康纳的那部，我觉得挺不错的，等等，你们总是告诉我，威尔，这跟你一天读十本书是一样的，千真万确，我两样都没做，我到底在忙什么，我明白了，我能，我能开始，不，我根本没有在听回答，安静，你知道的，我很想看到，我很想
to see Alex come back in right through that rear door there it's time for mom to do another yeah special guest spot when you're when you're done there visiting and working and stuff it's it going to be hard to say oh here it comes just to say bye bye I don't think we can ever use just why not why not lazy well here's the thing here's the thing I mean as well as much I want here because I live here I grew up here but then I moved to New York and now I live in LA but I have a place not close so technically I'm still not great like we've used that one a million no we might hear by the way so here I'm here with I'm here my dad's study and my dad went to the university of Manitoba and Manitoba I'm here
所以我在这是因为我想把……我在我父母的地方。哦，对，我是。威利，你正在读来自曼尼托巴的……他们有一种动物，那种有着全新的……全新的……是北美野牛。他刚才说什么？哦，曼尼托巴是加拿大的……是北美野牛吗？他刚才说的是那个吗？不，那是省份，他们的省级动物是……彻底崩溃，然后音乐响起。我们下周再跟听众们聊吧，今天就到这里。大家说再见吧！再见，大家！
my dad study my my parents are you don't need to you didn't need to reset yourself we're gonna cut we cut no we're not gonna cut it we're gonna keep in that you've you've reset yourself still rolling so I'm here because I wanted to include I'm here in my parents place oh yes I am will you're reading from Manitoba which they have you know the animal that's got a brand new brand new slate is the bye son bye what did he just say oh manitoba is a Canadian bison is that what he said no that's the province and that their their provincial animal is just a wipe out and then the music starts we'll talk to you next week listeners that's all we got let's you say bye right now goodbye everybody pasta smart smart smart
我爸爸研究我 我的父母是 你不需要 你不需要重置自己 我们要剪辑 我们剪辑 不 我们不剪辑 我们要保留你重新设置自己的部分 还在录制 所以我来这里是因为我想把 我在我父母家里哦是的 我在 你在读曼itoba省的 他们有你知道那个动物有个全新全新的白松 白松 他刚刚说什么哦曼itoba是一个加拿大野松 是他说的吗 不那是那个省 他们的省动物简直是一团糟 然后音乐就开始了 听众们我们下周再聊 我们就这些 现在说再见吧 大家的聪明聪明聪明
endless is 100% organic and artisan Lee handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry rub arm jarv and Bennett barbaco smart loss our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess 由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔马·贾夫和贝内特·巴尔巴科夫 100% 有机手工制作。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布。你可以在任何你听播客的地方收听，也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或 Wondery App 上订阅 Wondery Plus 来享受提前收听和无广告体验。本期节目暂无评论。点击任意句子即可发表评论。